[Music]  Rob and China we're hearing they have a  spin-off of course on e so what are you  most looking forward to that are we  gonna see their entire relationship  unfold baby bird well this series will  be leading up to the birth of birth will  be another special afterwards but these  are to have been covered in the media is  you know quite a bit recently I think  that they're excited to let cameras into  all aspects of their life it should be a  compelling fun show they're in a happy  great place with this baby on the way  happy are you for Rob though well I've  known him a long time he and I were we  used to work out together a couple years  ago was run on the treadmill together  push each other so I'm happy to see you  doing better everyone's happy that he  just found his peace happiness and  peaceful life  [Music]